corona testzentren im visier die
staatsanwaltschaft überprüft jetzt
abrechnungen auf betrug
gesundheitsminister spahn kündigte
schärfere kontrollen an
lukaschenko unter druck die
internationale kritik an machthaber in
belarus wächst der sucht unterstützung
beim russischen verbündeten und noch
zwei wochen bis zur em
bundestrainer löw will beim auftakt auf
die weltmeister muller und hummels
setzen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers die welt an diesem
samstag guten abend in allen sport
nachher in der sendung mit kristin otto
und auch fröhlichen fußballfans guten
abend wir beginnen heute mit dem wirbel
den berichte in deutschland ausgelöst
haben über möglichen großangelegten
abrechnungsbetrug in corona testzentren
der bundesgesundheitsminister hat
schärfere kontrollen angekündigt
kritiker werfen ihm vor es betrügern
durch laxe vorschriften leicht gemacht
zu haben
die betreiber von tests zentren müssen
für die kostenerstattung nicht einmal
nachweisen dass sie überhaupt antigen
schnelltests gekauft haben berichten ndr
wdr und süddeutsche zeitung
jetzt ermittelt die staatsanwaltschaft
thomas konsum berichtet vom einkaufen
gleich nebenan sich testen lassen
kostenlos ganz einfach verlockend
einfach vielleicht für manchen betreiber
den kosten zahlt der bund hier in essen
beobachteten wdr ndr und süddeutsche
zeitung versteckt 550 test willige kamen
aber dreimal mehr tests soll der
betreiber gemeldet haben eine bochumer
firma in köln ähnlicher verdacht wenig
testen viel abrechnen angeblich auch
ohne nachweis per twitter sagte der
bundesgesundheitsminister zu besuch in
südafrika
egal ob bei masken oder beim testen
jeder der die pandemie nutzt um sich
kriminell zu bereichern sollte sich
schämen für jedes testzentrum gilt es
meldet die anzahl der testungen an die
kassenärztliche vereinigung die zahlt
pro vorgang 18 euro lässt sich das geld
wiederum vom bund also vom steuerzahler
erstatten und ist empört es schon ein
wenig wilder westen bei den ganzen
testzentren wir haben ja grundsätzlich
situation dass die länder und damit in
der regel die gesundheitsämter
testzentrum beauftragen können das wird
zum teil extrem niedrige hand hat kein
mensch überprüft ob die qualifiziert
sind und was eben auch niemand prüft ob
wird
die menge menschen getestet wird die
angegeben wird aber wer soll prüfen das
land nrw sagt zuständig ist der bund der
habe aber versäumt konkrete vorgaben zu
machen das kritisieren auch
koalitionspartner und oppositionen also
wenn es stimmt dass die tests bezahlt
werden nur indem man sagt ich hab auch
leute getestet wird man das geld ohne
unterlagen einzureichen
dann ist die verordnung an der stelle
einfach murks das ist ja eine grundlage
auf die abgerechneten da ist dann ist es
einfach handwerklicher fuß des
gesundheitsministeriums die vergütung
für so ein test ist exorbitant teuer
viel zu hoch darauf haben wir als
bundestag auch vorher hingewiesen herr
spahn hat sich einfach darüber
hinweggesetzt und das wurde ihnen jetzt
eine stichprobenartige kontrollen
kündigte gesundheitsminister nun an
und er sagt auch die preise für
schnelltests seien gefallen deswegen
sinke auch die vergütung gegen eine
generelle impfkampagne für kinder hat
sich ein mitglied der ständigen
impfkommission gewandt der immunologe
christian bock daran sagte den
nürnberger nachrichten eine
impfempfehlung kann nicht einfach
deswegen ausgesprochen werden weil es
gerade gesellschaftlich oder politisch
opportun erscheint die wirksamkeit sei
zwar nachgewiesen aber in sachen
nebenwirkungen bei kindern und
jugendlichen fehlten noch ausreichend
daten schauen wir uns jetzt die korona
zahlen in deutschland an die sinken
weiter das robert koch institut meldet
5426 neue fälle binnen 24 stunden das
sind 1656 weniger als vergangenen
samstag 163 todesfälle kamen dazu die
bundesweite sieben tage incidents sinkt
auf 37,5 indien hatte sich vor einigen
wochen zum eine zu einem epizentrum der
korona pandemie entwickelt anfang des
monats lag die zahl der täglichen
neuansteckungen bei mehr als 400.000
mittlerweile ist sie nicht mehr ganz so
hoch doch von aufatmen kann keine rede
sein
seit tagen verbreitet sich auch noch der
sogenannte schwarze pilz unter tausenden
kurve patienten
das ist eine infektion die auf menschen
trifft die korona eigentlich schon
überstanden haben
einzelheiten jetzt von unserem
südostasien korrespondenten normen
odenthal die geschwollenen augen sind
ein symptom aber wenn es auftritt kann
es schon sehr spät sein
der schwarze pilzer den patienten längst
befallen greift organe an frisst sich
durch gewebe aggressiv jeder zweite
stirbt daran
mein freund hat sich mit dem schwarzen
pilz infiziert
vor drei tagen haben sie ihm den
unterkiefer weg operiert der doktor sagt
jetzt sie müssen auch ein auge entfernen
um sein leben retten zu können
ekomi pose wird durch einen schimmelpilz
ausgelöst in erde pflanzen in der luft
ein gesunder mensch hat genug
abwehrkräfte dass der pilz jetzt so
viele inder erwischt zeigt wie krank das
land gerade ist der schwarze pilz
befällt patienten die ein geschwächtes
immunsystem haben durch diabetes etwa
jetzt ist vor allem corona die große
gefahr der sich damit infiziert hat und
wer längerer zeit steroide dagegen
bekommt dessen immunsystem sehr anfällt
knapp 28 millionen inder haben sich mit
corona infiziert fast die hälfte erst in
den vergangenen zwei monaten und die
offiziellen zahlen spiegeln sicher nicht
die realität die ist wohl weit schlimmer
bokoni kose kommt jetzt noch dazu unser
kampf gegen korona steht nun vor einer
neuen herausforderung der schwarze pilz
breitet sich aus wir müssen uns darauf
vorbereiten und dagegen vorgehen
aber wie das medizinische system ist
ohnehin überlastet und auch wirksame
medikamente die es durchaus gibt fehlen
in indien
der schwarze pilz macht alles noch
düsterer so viel im moment zum thema
corona unser nächstes thema jetzt haben
auch die usa sanktionen gegen belarus
angekündigt wie vorher schon die eu sie
sollen staatsunternehmen treffen und
schlüsselfiguren des regimes von
machthaber alexander lukaschenko
hintergrund ist die erzwungene landung
eines ryanair flugzeugs in minsk danach
hatte belarus einen regimekritiker und
dessen freundin festgenommen die an bord
waren
lukaschenko sucht derweil unterstützung
beim russischen präsidenten
aber der protest geht weiter axel sturm
berichtet man nennt sie partisanen
menschen die auch in diesen zeiten den
mut haben in minsk die weiß rot weiße
flagge der opposition zu zeigen
freiheit für politische gefangene rufen
sie sie alle gehen ein großes risiko ein
in präsident lukaschenko start des tron
festnahmen haftstrafen misshandlungen
die protestbewegung endet nicht sie wird
immer fortbestehen
wir bereiten gerade einen generalstreik
vor wenn die menschen dazu bereit sind
werden sie wieder auf die straße gehen
die oppositionsführerin wünscht sich
neue massenproteste ruft zum
generalstreik auf gestern abend treffen
sich lukas schenk und der russische
präsident wladimir putin stärkt
lukaschenko den rücken in der ryanair
affäre
wir haben dieses treffen vereinbart
bevor vor dem gefühlsausbruch ja den
gefühlsausbruch aber wir haben ja auch
noch themen zu besprechen die nichts
damit zu tun haben die zwangs landung
der ryanair-maschine in minsk die
festnahme des journalisten prozess ebit
und seiner freundin die eu-sanktionen
die darauf folgten das nennen die beiden
staatschefs gefühlsausbruch
die usa schließen sich der kritik jetzt
an man werde gezielt schlüsselfiguren
des regimes in minsk sanktionieren heißt
es aus washington
eine reisewarnung für belarus hat das us
außenministerium bereits herausgegeben
ein weiteres land in einer tiefen
politischen krise ist kolumbien seit
wochen demonstrationen gegen die
regierung des südafrika mehr ikonischen
staates tausende fordern soziale und
politische reformen zentrum des protests
ist calli die drittgrößte stadt in
kolumbien
dorthin hat die regierung jetzt soldaten
geschickt bisher sind bei den unruhen
mehr als 40 menschen getötet worden
christoph bröcker rat berichtet mitten
im protest fallen schüsse
und keiner weiß von wem sie kommen
es ist diese unsicherheit die misstrauen
und escalation beflügeln in kolumbien
seit einem monat protestieren
zehntausende im ganzen land gegen ein
system das sie als ungerecht und korrupt
empfinden die mehrheit der demonstranten
ist friedlich eine klare politische
linie gibt es nicht wir sind weder links
noch rechts wir wollen dass sich das
land verändert und ein ende der
korruption
es sind vor allem frust und
zukunftssorgen die angst vor der
wachsenden armut die sich hier bahn
brechen
die behörden reagieren hilflos oder mit
gewalt
oft kommt beides zusammen 50 jahre
bürgerkrieg haben das land und vor allem
die sicherheitsorgane geprägt die
regierung behauptet die legale gruppen
würden die proteste unterwandern und
droht mit härte
die lage spitzt sich weiter zu vor allem
im westen kolumbiens in cali inseln der
anarchie haben keinen platz in unserem
land von heute an werden wir das militär
entsenden zur größtmöglichen
unterstützung der behörden sind karen
carney haben demonstranten seit wochen
straßen blockiert das geht vielen
bürgern zu weit denn die lebensmittel
werden knapp sie fordern beide seiten
auf sich zu einigen
der präsident sollte auf die jungen
leute und ihre forderungen eingehen
damit sie die blockade beenden
diese illegalen blockaden lehnen die
gesamte provinz regierung und vertreter
der demonstranten wollen weiter
miteinander reden
doch ein ausweg aus dem konflikt scheint
in weiter ferne
und jetzt in der sendung zurück nach
deutschland wo der mai jetzt gegen ende
endlich mal sonne bringt und wärmere
temperaturen
das schöne wetter ist auch ein
lichtblick für die gebeutelten
restaurants cafés biergärten das hier
sind bilder aus dem englischen garten in
münchen so sei es heute an vielen orten
in deutschland aus die ersten anzeichen
des sommers bisher war es jedoch
insgesamt einen frühling der nicht als
solcher im gedächtnis bleibt erst gab es
den kältesten april seit jahrzehnten und
auch der mai war bis vor kurzem nicht
nur kühl sondern auch noch ungewöhnlich
las all das ändert nichts daran dass
sich das klima global gesehen erwärmt
nikolaus albrecht jetzt über wetter
folgen in brandenburg für landwirt
stefan laskowski könnte die aussicht auf
die nächste regenfront gar nicht schöner
sein
ein ausnahme monat im sonst so trockenen
ja sogar von dürre geplagten brandenburg
der könnte jetzt schon hier rüber kommen
der schauer dass wir schon nicht die
frisch gepflanzten süßkartoffeln
brauchen gerade keine künstliche
bewässerung und aufwärts richter marco
hintze freut sich über saftige weiden
also für uns ist dieses frühjahr also
märchenhaft ist der mai kühl und nass
füllt dem bauern scheun und fass sagen
die alten ansprüche und wir wussten
schon gar nicht mehr wie sich das
anfühlt statistisch gesehen war dieser
april in deutschland der kälteste seit
40 jahren der mai bislang ebenfalls kühl
und eben ziemlich nass experten warnen
allerdings davor aus einer solchen
vorübergehenden großwetterlage wie sie
es nennen die falschen schlüsse
bezüglich des klimawandels zu ziehen
dass die weltweite erhitzung keine pause
macht das hat auch die welt meteorologie
organisation noch einmal bestätigt eine
neue abschätzung zeigt dass innerhalb
der nächsten fünf jahre eines dieser
jahre tatsächlich sogar die 15 grad
marke überschreiten könnte weniger
erfreut über das aktuell kühle
regenwetter die gastwirte seit gut einer
woche dürfen sie hier ihre terrassen
öffnen doch der große ansturm bleibt aus
wir haben einfach das problem dass wir
eben nicht nach drinnen dürfen das heißt
die gastronomie findet nur draußen statt
nur unter sonnenschirmen und das
wiederum führt dazu dass wir natürlich
nicht durchgehend auch wirklich betrieb
machen können immerhin ein wenig zeigt
sich die sonne dann doch noch und
vertraut man auf bauernregeln und
prognosen scheint sie im juni wieder
häufiger
ja selbst dann auf das kalte früher ein
schöner sommer erfolgt 1 wird fehlen
viele große musikfestivals sind ganz
abgesagt wegen corona doch einige
veranstalter wollen nicht aufgeben auf
jeden fall etwas auf die bühne bringen
was immer die pandemie regeln zu lassen
patricia schäfer jetzt aus würzburg wo
das mozartfest begonnen hat endlich mal
wieder große abendgarderobe zur
eröffnung des würzburger mozartfestes
strömt das publikum in den kaisersaal
der residenz zwar darf nur ein fünftel
der sitze besetzt werden
doch nach einer saison ohne live
konzerte ist das ein erlebnis nicht nur
fürs publikum
diese präsenz ist für uns musiker
wahnsinnig wichtig auch das ja dass wir
uns an jemanden richten können ja dieses
schöne beethoven wort von herzen möge es
wieder zu herzen gehen das funktioniert
eben in der musik über dieses live
erlebnis diese instrumente spürt man
sind für räume wie diesen gemacht bis
vor wenigen tagen war nicht klar ob und
unter welchen bedingungen live-konzerte
erlaubt sein würden
doch die intendantin des mozartfestes
bewahrte die nerven und ließ jedes
konzert in iks verschiedenen varianten
planen
das ging zum beispiel um abstände wie
nah oder nicht dürfen musiker zueinander
sitzen das heißt wie groß darf ein
orchester besetzt sein müssen wir
programme verkleinern und müssen die
musiker getestet sein dürfen sie nur
spielen wenn sie geimpft sind was trifft
für das publikum zu andere festivals
haben noch ein bisschen zeit die
festspiele mecklenburg-vorpommern zb
eröffnen in zwei wochen
dort dürfen in den nächsten monaten
sukzessive mehr zuschauer in die
konzertsäle
wir haben unsere hygiene konzept aus dem
letzten jahr auch noch einmal
überarbeitet und können da jetzt
wirklich ein sehr sicheres konzert
vergnügen bieten aber zum ende des
sommers sehen sind wir positiv gestimmt
dass es fast normale verhältnisse gibt
für das mozartfest gelten noch strengere
regeln dafür erklingen sogar zwei von
mozart eigenen instrumenten zum neustart
nach corona
den meister hätte es wohl gefreut
von herzen zu herzen jetzt der sport mit
christine gibt es auch viel vorfreude
ein stück normalität kehrt nachher ins
fußballgeschehen zurück unter hohen
auflagen 416 1500 fans die ins stadion
dürfen zum englischen duell in champions
league finale und auch ringsum
partystimmung in portugals hafenstadt
porto ist eine fanmeile 12.000 tickets
haben die vereine von chelsea und
manchester city bekommen aber es sind
mehr angereist um die zeit nach cupid zu
feiern
wir haben gestern abend erst erfahren
dass wir kommen können und sind so
glücklich
wir mussten eine ganze handvoll kurve
tests machen
wir geben 500 pfund nur für tests aus
ein test verein reise einer vor dem
stadion und eventuell noch einer
flugreise porto und die veranstalter
wollen mit einem sicherheitskonzept das
endspiel zum symbol machen für einen
neuanfang wie hätten wir müssen zum
normalen leben zurückkehren was immer
normal heißt wir müssen einige risiken
eingehen in einer stadt die sehr vom
tourismus liegt
zu den risiken gehört dass die fans die
in portugal gültigen abstandsregeln sehr
großzügig interpretieren bewohner freuen
sich trotzdem
das geschäft war sehr schlecht jetzt
beginnt für unser café die rettung
das stadion ist eigentlich zu klein für
ein endspiel aber dank der reduzierten
zuschauerzahl ergab sich für porto eine
chance die mannschaften die in nicht
einmal zwei stunden hier gegeneinander
antreten dürfen sich gleichwohl auf eine
sehr lebendige kulisse freuen
na hoffentlich geht alles gut und eine
zusammenfassung gibt es im aktuellen
sportstudio darin ebenfalls auch die
ersten free tv bilder das
relegations-rückspiel holstein kiel
gegen den ersten fc köln erst
aussortiert und nun als leitwölfe wieder
dabei bundestrainer joachim löw
versprach in seefeld mats hummels und
thomas müller zumindest für die em
auftakt spiele eine einsatzgarantie die
em-fahrer drücken aufs tempo sind schon
vor dem heutigen abend training aktiv
am zweiten tag in den tiroler bergen der
bundestrainer gezielt die rückkehr von
mats hummels und thomas müller
verteidigt beide sollen tragende rollen
einnehmen müssen sich gleichzeitig aber
auch den konkurrenzkampf stellen
natürlich wissen aber auch bei den
spielern dass sie natürlich auch
leistungen bringen müssen das vorangehen
müssen eine einsatz garantie über ein
ganzes turnier habe ich ihnen nicht
gegeben löw muss mindestens noch bis
anfang nächster woche auf die
schlüsselspieler goretzka genommen und
groß verzichten
holpriger auftakt für zehnkampf
weltmeister niklas kaul bei der olympia
qualifikation in götzis nach langer
pause lief er die 100 meter in schwachen
11,37 sekunden und lag nach der ersten
disziplin nur auf dem vorletzten platz
danach kann man besser in schwung und
verbesserte sich zur halbzeit immerhin
auf position elf mit 4100 26 punkten
wohl wissend tag 2 ist meistens ein tag
sind gespannt
danke dir so vom kalten mai hatten das
ja schon in dieser sendung jetzt kommen
die wärmeren aussichten für die letzten
paar tage nehmen wir gerne mit details
gleich von katja hornuf dann empfehle
ich ihnen natürlich das heute schon ein
mit dem kollegen claus kleber um 22 uhr
wir freuen uns auf sie morgen wieder
punkt 7 bis dann wenn sie mögen einen
angenehmen abend hinein matches
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren bis
zum mittag hatte sich die hochnebeldecke
hier in norddeutschland mehr oder
weniger aufgelöst dann sagen sie auch an
der schlei die sonne
derweil gab es in süddeutschland einige
quellwolken regenschauer blieben aber
die ausnahme
das macht auch in der nacht so da ist es
meist klar und im westerzgebirge sinken
die werte bis 2 grad
und morgen gibt es dann einen sonnen
sonntag und am alpenrand da kann die
sonne derzeit 15 eineinhalb stunden über
dem horizont stehen hier an der grenze
zu dänemark sind das sogar fast 17
stunden und morgen werden wir die sonne
sogar 11 bis 16 stunden lang sehen
können es gibt also nur ganz wenige
wolken das hat allerdings konsequenzen
für den uv index mit heller haut
bekommen sie bereits nach weniger als 20
minuten ungeschützt bei einem uv-index
von acht einen sonnenbrand
morgen wird dazu auch noch ein kühlender
nordost wird deswegen liegen die
temperaturen in sachsen und in bayern
auch nur so bei 16 bis 18 grad noch
kühler ist es nur an der see sonst aber
werden doch angenehme 18 bis 23 grad
erreicht
und in der neuen woche geht es sonnig
und recht warm weiter damit ein schönes
wochenende